- Hi, beautiful people,
how are you today?
Thank you for being here.
Before I begin,
let's take a moment
to acknowledge
that we're gathered
on the ancestral and unseeded
lands of the Massachusetts
and the Wampanoag peoples.
We pay respect to their
elders past and present.
Thank you so much to everyone
involved with the Radcliffe
Institute.
You make we fellows feel not
only beloved but protected,
and that's rare in
this world of ours.
I feel less dread here
than in most places.
Thank you, Meredith.
And thank you to
Suzanne for endowing
this amazing fellowship.
It has blown my mind in
100 different ways, which
someday I'll be able
to understand, not yet,
but someday.
My fellow fellows, you
people in the audience,
you;re people such genius that
I come from your talks quivering
with ideas and with emotion.
And that too is rare in my life.
I don't have my
research partner,
my undergraduate research
partner, Patricia Liz here.
She did all of the aesthetic
work in this slide show.
I don't know how
to do a slide show.
I'm kind of a Luddite.
Thank you, Patricia.
You're wonderful.
She's also a great poet.
Someday you'll know her name.
I mean you know her name now.
I don't know if the Professor
Richard Moran is here.
If he is thank you for letting
me take your Proust class.
It is blowing my mind.
To my mom who is in the
audience, you're the best.
Thank you for being here.
So what I'm going
to do today is I'm
going to talk a little
bit about my next project,
The Vaster Wilds and then I'll
read just a little bit from it.
And I did this
because every time
that I sit down at a
blank page, I wonder,
how is it that people come up
with ideas for books again?
I don't know.
And this is my
sixth published one
and I've written
probably four others
that were just disasters.
So I wanted to think about
how these books come to life.
And the first metaphor
that came to mind
is probably
incredibly grandiose.
In fact, it's very
grandiose, but it's
the only one that came to mind.
So it is this.
Nuclear fusion.
So nuclear fusion is
a reaction in which
two or more atomic
nuclei are combined
to form one or more
different atomic nuclei
in subatomic particles.
Now there are physicists in the
room who can school me on this.
But for me, this is the
way that I see ideas
coming to life in a novel.
A single idea for me is inert.
It doesn't actually come to life
until two or more other ideas
crash into it and become this.
Now this is, I think
this is amazing.
This is an artificial sun that
is being developed in China.
And isn't it great?
It's so cool that
there's an artificial sun
in the world and so terrifying.
All right.
So the first-- I'm going to
go through six ideas that
crashed together and came
together into The Vaster Wilds.
So the first one is this.
This is Mary Rowlandson.
This is a frontispiece from one
of her editions of her books.
Those of you who don't
remember high school
may not remember
that Mary Rowlandson
is this very incredible figure.
She was born in 1637.
She died in 1711.
And she was one of the settlers
on the Massachusetts frontier.
In the middle of King
Philip's war, February 10,
1675, at Lancaster in
Massachusetts not far
from here, there was a raid
on the town of settlers
by the combined forces of
the Wampanoag, Narragansett,
and Nashaway peoples.
In this raid, 13 English
people were killed
and 24 were taken captive,
including Mary Rowlandson
and her three children.
Two of those children
were separated from her,
and the youngest child was
6 years old and five months.
She's very specific about this.
And the little girl was
wounded very badly in the raid.
And for the next 11 days,
Mary carried this little girl.
Until on the 11th
day, the girl died.
So Mary was taken captive.
And it was a late winter.
It was harsh.
It was unforgiving.
It was during a time of
absolute hunger, famine.
And Mary Rowlandson
didn't speak the language
of the Native American
people around her,
so she didn't understand
their culture.
She didn't understand what was
happening to her basically.
About 11 weeks later,
she was ransomed
to a group of people who
paid for her to come back
to her husband.
And later, her
two older children
were brought back to her.
And she wrote of her
narrative of this.
And she wrote it, it's
a very famous book.
And she wrote it in
a series of removes.
So every time that
the Native Americans
got up and fled the
onslaught of the soldiers,
each one was called a remove.
And so I'm going to read
to you an entire remove.
This is the 14th remove, because
I want you to hear her voice.
It's so extraordinary.
OK, she says, now
must we pack up
and be gone from this
thicket, bending our course
toward the bay towns.
I having nothing to
eat by the way this day
but a few crumbs of cake
that an Indian gave my girl
the same day we were taken.
She gave it me and I
put it in my pocket.
There it lay till it was so
moldy for want of good baking
that one could not tell
what it was made of.
It fell all to crumbs and
grew so dry and hard that it
was like little flints.
And this refreshed me many
times when I was ready to faint.
It was in my thoughts
when I put it in my mouth
that if ever I
returned, I would tell
the world what a blessing the
Lord gave to such mean food.
As we went along, they killed
a deer with a young one in her.
They give me a piece of the
fawn and it was so young
and tender that one might
eat the bones, as well
as the flesh.
And yet I thought it very good.
When night came, we sat down.
It rained, but they
quickly got a bark wigwam
where I lay dry that night.
I looked out in the
morning and many of them
had lain in the
rain all night, I
saw by their
reeking or the smoke
coming off of their bodies.
Thus the Lord dealt
mercifully with me many times,
and I fared better
than many of them.
In the morning, they took
the blood of the deer
and put it into the
paunch and so boiled it.
I could eat nothing of that,
though they eat it sweetly.
And yet they were so
nice and other things
that when I had fetched water
and had put the dish I dipped
the water with into the kettle
of water which I brought,
they would say that they
would knock me down,
for they said it was
a sluttish trick.
So they were much more
hygienic than she was is
what she is saying in the end.
Sluttish trick just means dirty.
Her narrative was
actually published here
in Cambridge,
Massachusetts in 1682.
And it had a preface likely
by Cotton Mather, that Puritan
preacher, and was so deeply
inflected the whole way
through with piety,
that many scholars do
believe that he had a
heavy hand in the text.
So I remembered Mary Rowlandson.
She dug at me.
I didn't know why.
I didn't understand
what it was about her
that was so interesting.
And so I started reading
other captivity narratives
of early American women.
Cotton Mather actually wrote
his own captivity narrative
of Hannah Dustin,
who is this woman who
had been taken by the
Abanachy and apparently
in scouts 10 Native
Americans on her way fleeing.
There was Elizabeth
Hanson in New Hampshire.
Susanna Willard Johnson,
also New Hampshire.
And what I found from these, I
found this kernel of an idea,
that this was one of the first
forms of American women's
literary storytelling.
Yet at the same time,
these narratives
were controlled by the
men who published them.
They were edited by men.
And often they were
as told to men.
And they were published by men.
So who knows really, what the
actual voices of the women are?
Once in a while, in the course
of reading these narratives,
you hear something that
rings absolutely like
a soul talking to your own.
But you never quite know if
these women were actually--
these were their words
and their experiences.
At the same time
also in 2019, it
is hideous to read these now.
Because they are tools
of absolute propaganda.
And at the time they were used
as Puritan self-justification
for stealing the land,
for the acts of genocide
that were perpetrated, for
making Native Americans seem
other or barbaric and
almost giving justification
to the colonialists
to take their land
and to treat them as barbarians.
It's brutal to read these now.
Yet at the same time, I fell
in love with one narrative.
And this is a little bit blurry.
But this is Mary Jemeson's
captivity narrative.
She was captured in
1775 when she was 15.
But she grew to love the
Seneca with whom she lived.
And she had two husbands
and children with them.
And she was given the chance to
go back, but she chose not to.
She chose to stay
with the Seneca.
And I found her
really fascinating.
And I wanted to think a
little bit more about her.
Now the second thing sort of
coming into the first atom,
was Robinson Crusoe.
So I remembered Robinson Crusoe.
I have to, before
you talk about it,
I have to read the subtitle
because I just love it so much.
Are you ready?
I am going to try
to do in one breath.
The life and strange,
surprising adventures
of Robinson Crusoe
of York, mariner,
who lived eight and
20 years all alone
in an uninhabited island
on the coast of America
near the mouth of the
Great River Nookie,
having been cast on
shore by shipwreck
wherein all the men perished
but himself, with an account how
he was at last strangely
delivered by pirates.
Love it so much.
And I read this when I was
17, like the Mary Rowlandson
captivity narratives.
And I remembered that the first
part of Robinson Crusoe, he
was actually captured by
a Moore, which is a North
African of Muslim belief.
And he was held for
two years as a slave.
So I thought, OK,
there's some sort
of connection with these
captivity narratives.
And I reread this
book all the time,
because I find it so
fascinating because there's
no interiority in
Robinson Crusoe.
There's no self
reflection really.
And so that there's so
little self reflection,
there's a lot of a litany of
what happens, what happens,
what he does, what happens.
That sometimes there
are these objects
that begin to contain all of
the emotion of the human who
is regarding them.
So for instance, the day that
he's shipwrecked, he looks out
and he's just devastated.
And he says, reflecting upon all
my comrades that were drowned
and that there should
not be one soul saved
but myself, for, as
for them, I never
saw them afterwards
or any sign of them
except three of
their hats, one cap,
and two shoes that
were not fellows.
Oh my god, it's so good.
So I reread this
and I thought, and I
got snagged on this one moment.
So Robinson Crusoe, he's trying
to create a life for himself
amongst these goats.
And he decides to make
for himself a table.
And I started thinking
about this table
because in an England
household of the time,
the table was the place around
which everyone gathered.
And so how poignant
is it that he's
making a place for himself,
around which nobody else
will gather but him, right?
And then I read that he
said, if I wanted a board,
I had no other way but
to cut down a tree,
set it on an edge before
me and hew it flat
on either side with
my ax till I had
brought it to be
as thin as a plank
and then dub it
smoothed my adze.
It is true by this method I
could make but one board out
of a whole tree.
But this I had no
remedy for but patience,
anymore than I had for the
prodigious deal of time
and labor which it took me to
make up a plank or a board.
So I mean, that's
really poignant too.
He had to cut down a whole
tree to make a plank, right?
That's really extraordinary
and wonderful.
But then I thought
about this further.
And I thought that
this is very strange.
This is almost an imposition of
England upon this wild island,
right?
There's a right angles.
He's trying to make right
angles in this place that's
full of not right angles.
And it's starting to
feel almost as a motif
of an imposition of puritanical
ideas of work and suffering
and commerce.
And I am very ambivalent
about puritanism and work
and suffering and commerce.
So I was really, really
concerned about this,
as almost this too felt almost
propagandic in some ways.
And that made me sad.
The third element that crashed
into the first two was--
I read an article.
Now this, I read an article
in National Geographic
about Jamestown, the first
English settlement that lasted.
And in this article, it was
shown that archaeologists
found the skull and shinbone
of a 14-year-old girl who
had been cannibalized.
Now in five of the
primary sources,
people had said at the time
during the starving time, when
everyone was dying,
there was no food.
They were eating their horses.
They were eating vermin.
You know, they're
boiled their shoes,
that there was cannibalism.
But this is the first
time there's actually
evidence, empirical
evidence, from the bones.
And I thought this was amazing.
This was really strange.
So I started looking
into Jamestown.
And this is Jamestown before the
starving time of 1609 to 1610.
And as I was looking
into this research,
I started reading
primary sources.
I read all of John
Smith's narratives.
And I love John
Smith as a character
because he was a braggart.
He was a liar.
He was amazing.
I read A True Relation
and Observations
by George Percy, A True
Discourse of the Present
State of Virginia
by Ralph Hamor,
and all bunches of letters.
And then I started
reading secondary sources.
Still I still had no
idea what I was going
to do with all this stuff.
Now, I was pretty
sure at this point
that I was going to
write historical fiction.
And in the past.
I said I would never write
historical fiction again.
And I think I said this
because in literary fiction,
historical fiction is
often looked down upon.
And I have theories
about this, which
I'm having to happy
about in the Q&A.
But one of the
theories that I have
is that historical
fiction is often,
even by very excellent
writers, treated
as tourism into the past.
And I didn't want to do this.
If I had to write another
historical fiction book,
I wanted to write something
that was oppositional, that was
talking about the current day.
Because I think that if
you're not doing that
in historical fiction, why?
Why bother?
And I'm not a historian.
So what I think a historian
does, and there's so
many great historians
in the room,
I've seen all of
their work, thank you.
I'm not a historian.
What they do is they make
this beautiful lace work out
of facts and ideas
and inferences.
But I think the job of a
person who's writing fiction
within history is to
take this lace work
and to gently tease apart one
of the holes and look through.
And you try not to break
the threads if you do.
You build, they'll tell you.
But you know, you
try to look through.
So that's what I wanted to do.
So I eventually
succumbed to this idea
that I was going to write
this historical fiction.
Now these are my ideas
about, sort of encapsulated,
about how to do this right,
how to do this morally.
And the Hilary Mantel one
is really interesting.
I think that she's probably
one of the people who
does the best historical
fiction writing out there.
She says, when you choose
a novel to tell you
about the past, you're
putting in brackets
the historical accounts,
which may or may not
agree with each other
and actively requesting
a subjective interpretation.
If you're buying
a replica or even
a faithful photographic
reproduction,
you're buying a painting with
the brush strokes left in.
That's beautiful right?
That's a beautiful way
of thinking about this.
And then Walter been
Benjamin actually
has this statement which goes
against some of the things
that Hilary Mantel
actually does.
But he says, it is
more arduous to honor
the memory of the nameless
than that of the renowned.
So this is what I wanted
to do with this project.
I wanted to honor
someone who is nameless.
Now the fourth and fifth things,
I don't have a slide with this
because I put it in today and
my research assistant put it in.
I was really, I've always been
interested in survivalism,
in eschatology, in
wilderness survival.
That's the fourth.
And the fifth is, I started
this at the end of 2016,
which you remember, right?
And I was so angry.
And I'm still so angry.
But I just hated the patriarchy
so much at that point.
I just wanted to
throw a grenade at it.
And I was, I was
looking at the way
that the patriarchy
reverberated out into our lives,
and how at the
beginning there could
have been an
alternative to the way
that we have been taught
to see the formation
of the American
culture as it is today.
And it devastated me.
So I wanted to write this
thing as a vision of--
you'll see.
I wanted to-- I wanted
to write a fusion.
I wanted to write a
female Robinson Crusoe,
reimagining a girl fleeing
Jamestown in the Starving Time.
Eventually, she joined
Native Americans.
It's a captivity
narrative sort of that's
not propaganda or
puritanical justification,
but one in which as her
body moves outwards away
from Jamestown, and the
spring begins to warm she
generally loses some of
her preconceived ideas
that she has just
taken for granted all
throughout her life.
And it's a very physical book.
So I wanted to
think of it almost
as an anti-captivity narrative.
In some ways this is,
it's more complex possibly
than in captivity narrative.
Now, I wrote a couple drafts.
And I like to write many drafts.
I write a whole thing, throw it
out, start over again, throw it
out.
And I do it all longhand.
And I will talk
to you later about
why, if you are
interested in the Q&A,
it's really long,
my explanation.
And so, on about the
fifth or sixth draft,
I remembered one of the great
loves of my life, William
Shakespeare.
I love him so much.
And I tend to try
to read Shakespeare
as much as possible.
But I realize that
Shakespeare was
contemporaneous with this
character that I was creating.
And so the quote is, I can call
spirits from the vasty deep.
And I was reading
Henry IV Part One,
and I thought, oh,
the vasty deep, that's
a great title for a book.
But then I thought,
know the vasty
wilds, because
she's in the wilds.
But I thought, nobody
knows what Vasty is,
so it has to be vaster,
the vaster wilds.
So that's where the title
of this book comes from.
And then I got so, I
kind of get over the top.
I get very in love
with the things
that I'm studying at the time.
I got so in love
with Shakespeare,
I tried to write an entire
draft in iambic pentameter.
And that was
actually the most fun
I've ever had writing
in my entire life.
It was just joyous.
And I think sometimes you
have to mix it up like that.
I mean, I've been doing
this for 20 years.
So I have to, I have to
make it fun for myself.
So I did a whole draft
in iambic pentameter,
threw it out immediately
because it was just failed.
And what I had to
do then was try
to find a kind of language
that wasn't archaic the way
that we see the language of the
17th century as archaic now,
but felt as fresh
then, as it was--
as fresh now as it
was then, right?
Almost newborn.
Because back then,
there's so many influences
changing the English language.
And if you read some
of the primary sources,
you know that none
of the spellings
are at all standardized.
So it's actually very
fun to read it and try
to hear it and try to hear what
it is that they're actually
saying at the time.
So I wanted to find a
language that was fresh.
And if Professor
Joyce Chaplin is here,
I want to say thank you.
Because she read it for
possibly anachronisms
that I had definitely put in
to the book at that point.
And then one more revision.
I started making sure
that my understanding
of the Native American world
of the time in particular
in which my characters
is living is correct.
Because it has to be
absolutely correct or else
I will be re-perpetrating
the acts of colonialism
upon these populations.
So I've been in conversation
with particularly Lisa Brooks,
who wrote this amazing book.
I don't know if
you've ever read it.
But it's in one
chapter in particular,
she talks about Mary Rowlandson.
But she talks about her from
the other side of the tapestry.
And she gives sort of, the
way that Mary Rowlandson sees
barbarism, she gives
really clear explanations
based on the cultures in
which Mary Rowlandson is
sort of meeting.
And Mary Rowlandson had no
language or understanding
of the culture.
And so she just, she had no idea
what she was coming up against.
So I've been talking to Lisa
Brooks, Kahente Horn-Miller,
and Alyssa Mt.
Pleasant-- all of these great
Native American academics--
to try to make sure that
I'm not being a jerk.
And so that's where I
am with this so far.
And I'm going to read
a little bit of it now.
I'm slightly anxious about
this, because I don't share
my work unless it's finished.
So here it goes.
All right.
This is from the beginning.
The moon hid itself
behind the clouds.
The winds spat icy
snow at angles.
Close to the great black
wall of the palisade,
there was a split seemingly
too small for human passage.
Through it the girl
slipped from her life
and into the black and
terrible wilderness.
Her face was hooded and she
was slight, born bony and short
but the feminine has
drifted down yet starker
to root and string and fiber.
Even so starved and blinded
by the dark, she was quick.
She stumbled with her
first step and nearly fell,
but caught herself
and began to run, now
going fast over the frozen ruts
of the field, the corn that
came up in summer black
and stunted with blight.
Swifter, girl, she told herself.
And her legs in their panic
and anguish moved faster.
The good boots
she had stolen off
the dead son of a
gentleman, the thick cloak
she'd stolen off her
own mistress, who
wept even now inside
that hellish place,
diminishing its grip on her
with each step she took away.
There was a glimmer on
the dark ground ahead.
She knew it was the
shirt of a man who'd
been caught worming
his way to the forest
when, with no sound at all,
the worst and bloodiest
of the naturals had loomed
up out of the shadows.
The warrior, two heads
taller than the men
of the fort, who made
himself more terrible
by wearing black swans wings
outstretched upon his back.
Then this most dangerous of the
natural men, had in silence,
lifted the creeping
man by the hair
and it cut a second mouth
into creeping man's throat
and dropped him there to
spill his heart's blood
into the frozen earth, where he
lay splayed still after a week.
For the soldiers of the Fort
had become too weak and cowardly
in their hunger to
fetch his body back.
She passed the dead man
and his lingering reek
and was nearly to the
woods when she stumbled,
this time in fear.
For now before her she saw
the naturals lurking in ambush
in every deeper, blacker
shadow of each tree.
Yet she went on.
And each imagined natural
and terrified passing
revealed himself to be
merely shadow again.
She had left everything
behind her in fleeing,
a roof, a home, a country,
a language, the only family
she had known, innocence,
her own knowledge of herself.
Do not think of it,
girl, she told herself,
or else you shall die of grief.
And she did not
turn back to look
on the red gleam of the
small fires inside the fort
as they shown in
the night sky above.
She was devout.
She listened when the minister
read from the Good Book.
She had learned her lesson
from the wife of Lot.
She ran and she was nothing.
In this wilderness,
she was no one.
The dark rendered the self
she'd owned down to nothing.
Yet a nothing is a
thing with no past.
A nothing could be free.
Inside the forest the wind
calmed and removed its hands
from her cheeks and
under her skirts.
It was warmer, though
by no means warm.
She stopped and pressed
her for head to a tree
and its rough skin
held her there.
What light that should
have fallen from the sky
could not, because all was
covered in a thickness of cloud
and the forest before her
was dense and dense and dark
as pitch.
Pocks of snow shined
darkly here and there
within the pits of trees.
Her breath was ragged
and she quieted it.
She let the silence
seep back in and allied
the crashing of her footsteps.
Surely it had been loud
enough to have woken
what ears might have been near.
Perhaps even now the naturals
were following or silently
behind her, stalking
her like prey.
She listened over the scrape
and bow of the wind, cold trunk
upon cold trunk picking shrieks
as though tuning fiddles,
but heard no footsteps,
no breaking twigs.
And at last not far from
where she stood listening,
she heard the rasp of the
stream that she knew was nearby
running under its shell of ice.
She pressed on as
silently as she could.
And when she found
the ice with her feet,
she followed it northward
and into the black.
For some time, she
gingerly slid up the stream
until she saw a deeper
gleam near her boot.
And knowing it to
be flowing water,
she bent and took off
the leather and gloves
with her teeth and pressed her
frozen hands between her legs
until they thawed
enough to move,
then opened the sack
she had been carrying
in one frozen fist, and
dipped the pewter cup
she'd stolen into the
water and drank deeply.
The cold water sliced
down the center of her
like the tip of a knife.
It made her shudder and her
teeth chattered in her head.
And then she replaced the cup
and tied the sack to her waist,
lifting her cloak and
gowns to place it there.
Her bones shouted,
and her head swam,
but with aching bones and slow
blood, she pressed on again.
Her stomach, emptied
these three days,
protested at its
fullness of water.
She began to run again
and her body warmed
and her breath rasped, softer
now against the cold air.
Now that her legs had
reached a good warmth,
and the pulse of nerves
that had sent her running
had faded into the
constant forward motion,
and the harshness
of her breathing
had softened into
a rhythm, her brain
could loosen up into wonder.
She had until now,
been moving herself
in recoil from the worst
thing she'd yet seen
or could imagine, the
terrible thing in the yard
that she could
never after unsee.
And still the minister's
hand was still,
it was so hard upon her
throat, that when she swallowed
she could feel the ghost
of it there, squeezing.
She could smell his
sour breath in her nose.
She could feel the
choking in her whole body
which sorely needed to rest.
And even as she
ran, before her eyes
fell the vision of the
mistress, weeping on her knees
in the light of the fire
reaching her hand out greedily.
She shunted it away
behind a door in her mind
that she closed
and locked tight.
She had placed a great
many things in her life
behind this door in her mind.
The grief too great, it
would burn her up as fuel.
She knew that there
would be no return.
She could only move
into the nothing,
the great vast dark in the
desert waste of this land.
The sacrifices of God or
a broken spirit, a broken
and a contrite heart.
Oh, God doubt will not despise.
You sinner, she said to herself.
What is it that you have done?
What have you done?
It fell upon her all in a
heap that she was venturing
into this virgin immensity
with its great hard perils,
known its serpents and lions
and many fanged winter itself,
but also there was awaiting
her great perils unknown,
monsters yet uncharted and
unknown to the imagination
of men, difficulties
never yet returned from
and reported in the letters
and books that men produce.
And she knew further, of
all the unknown perils
that stalked her.
The worst by far were
the faceless naturals
whose hatred for
her people burned
in their mysterious hearts,
whose language would
be a tangle of sounds, who would
view her in what strange light
and deal with her in
what unknown manner.
So savage were they
that the rumors
rippled outwards and redoubled
back in waves of terror.
There were tales of
a soldier whose head
had been found
cleaved from his body,
with bread stuffed into his
mouth as if to mock the famine
the settler suffered.
There were tales of men
creeping back to fort,
pressing their hands to
staunch the blood pouring
from their heads, all
hair and flesh ripped off
to the bony skull.
And there'd been
a soldier, it was
said, in the first
wave of settlers, who'd
come across one of the
natural girls in the forest
and starved to madness
for the company of women,
he had pushed this natural girl
down and had his way with her.
She screamed and wept, and he
left her lying there bleeding.
And one day, when this
man was out in the bay
gathering oysters, he looked
up to find his companions had
disappeared from around him.
And the birds in the
trees had gone silent.
And in a blink, as though
they had been magicked out
of the fog upon the
waters, the natural women
had silently surrounded him.
Before he could
cry out, they put
a leather thong in his mouth.
So he was made mute
and could not scream.
And they dragged him away
with them by the head.
And then that same
night, four women
tied him naked as a
newborn babe to the trees
visible from the
gate of the fort,
legs and arms
painfully outspread.
Then they built a
great fire before him
so that his pale skin glowed
in the dark like a star.
And they loosed the
thong in his mouth
so his screams could be heard
in the heart of the fort.
And all at once, the many
women poured naked out
of the dark forest with
sharpened oyster shells
in their hands.
And with these as knives, the
women slowly flayed the man.
This is really, really bloody.
First the skin of
his eyelids, so he
had no choice but to watch
what they were doing to him.
Then the skin of
his arms and legs
and belly, which they
threw into the fire
before his peeled eyes.
And then his tongue
from his mouth,
so he could yet scream
through the clotting blood.
And then his privy
members which they slowly
removed, the figs first
and then the manhood.
And at this at last,
he lost his senses,
and they waited for
him to wake again
before they let his
parts fall, plump
and spitting into the fire.
Only then in mercy, did
they slit his throat
and let the hot blood
pour out of him and steam
upon the ground.
This was the savagery of
the people of these parts.
And she prayed they
did not catch her,
for there was no telling
what they would do.
For they did hate her own
people, and deeply so.
And it was no secret what
men across the world entire
did to women of the enemy
in times of war and strife.
But under these
thoughts of the naturals
there sang a low
counterpoint in her mind.
And she saw in a vision,
how in her own native city,
the heads of the enemies
of the late queen
had been stuck on the pikes
of the great bridge, the way
that in a harsh wind
their beards flapped,
and it seemed that they
were silently screaming,
and beneath the carts piled
with vegetables were rolling
stupidly to the markets.
And farmers rode
stolidly with no notice
those skulls on the pikes.
And furthermore,
that though it was
said that when women
and children of the fort
disappeared during the
famine, that the naturals had
come through in the
night and stolen them,
she'd always imagined that
perhaps the cleverest women,
seeing danger on both sides,
had taken their children
and fled to the naturals,
who were also hungry but had
food enough for all to survive,
and would grudgingly take them
in as slaves.
For mothers, having
already lost their liberty
when they bore their children,
understood the delicate balance
between the price of freedom and
the price of their children's
lives.
You know what?
I'm going to stop there
to the blood and death.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.